et c'est dans ce contexte que les
policiers manifestent leur ras-le-bol la
nuit notamment paris en cause des
déclarations récentes du ministre de
l'intérieur sur les sanctions pour les
fonctionnaires en cas de soupçons avérés
de racisme une polémique dont se sont
emparés certains leaders politiques
c'est le cas notamment de jean luc
mélenchon qui souhaitent je cite une
police aussi désarmé possible pour
qu'elle inspire le respect alors qu'à
droite on demande davantage de fermeté
alors faut-il désarmer la police
française elle est il notamment
intervenir plus tôt et plus fort après
les inédites opération de représailles
de tchétchènes à dijon c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soit et pour en
débattre nous sommes en direct avec jean
lain la capelle député européen délégué
national du rassemblement national
bonsoir jean lain la capelle merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
à vos côtés vikash dhorasoo ancien
footballeur proche de la france
insoumise bonsoir vittel dhorasoo merci
d'être avec nous alors une police aussi
désarmé que possible pour qu'elle
inspire le respect je reprends les mots
de jean luc mélenchon c'est une bonne
idée
il cache dhorasoo les policiers qui
inspire d'ailleurs plus de crainte que
le respect oui là des familles déjà moi
j'irai plus loin il parlera en inspirant
de ce qui se passe aux etats unis
il ya des endroits on notamment
minneapolis angola la des finances et à
ordiphones en en anglais voilà alors de
lui donner moins de moyens financiers et
prendre cet argent et l'utiliser
évidemment pour régler les problèmes
sociaux juste l'exemple d'aujourd'hui si
on avait donné plus de moyens à
l'hôpital hôpital public
les infirmiers et les infirmières les
personnels soignants ne serait pas dans
la rue on n'aurait pas eu besoin de la
police en face qui vient de réprimer
quand même les gens qu'on applaudit c
est qu on ne compte qu'on présentait
comme nos héros il ya quelques semaines
évidemment moi je
je ne veux pas de cette folie on veut de
la justice et c'est ce qu'on n'a pas en
ce moment
jean marie cappel oui donc city monsieur
mélenchon qui demandait à ce que ont
désarmé les policiers et puis ce matin
il demandé à ce qu'on désarme les les
gangs et les bandes de tchétchènes
notamment donc il veut que l'envoi des
forces de police en petites socquettes
avec avec les mains dans le dos on sait
c'est une hérésie de gagner avant que
que de formuler cela je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on à l'illustration d'une
faillite de l'état en quelque sorte et
c'est pas à d'ailleurs la première fois
que on assiste à des scènes comme celle
de dijon parce que ça arrive en ce
moment également à nice et arrive à tout
ce qui arrivait à marseille vous avez
des bandes structuré armée qui font la
loi en toute impunité il a fallu quand
même trois jours pour que le ministre la
défense donne des consignes mises de
l'intérieur par donne des consignes a
offert de l'or pour intervenir afin de
neutraliser la situation à dijon 3 jours
où donc ces bandes armées ont pu faire
leur loi régler leur compte tout seul en
toute impunité
c'est la triste conséquence d'une
immigration incontrôlée et d'un laxisme
politique qui marque 30 ont clairement
on essayait d'acheter la paix sociale
dans ces quartiers où on est à dix
finalement tous les habitants et on a
investi des milliards et des milliards
justement dans les huiles de la ville on
revient que ça ne marche à rien ça ne
mène à rien et que finalement ça aboutit
à quelque chose de très dangereux qui le
séparatisme république a indiqué ge
dhorasoo il ya plusieurs idées dans ce
que dit jean lain la capelle d'une part
on aurait peut-être intervenue trop tard
il ya aussi cette notion d' immigration
incontrôlée quelle est votre réaction
mais évidemment je suis pas vraiment
d'accord alors au bout de moi le les
guerres de gangs dijon et cetera voilà
on pourra en parler moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est cette police coq est
aujourd'hui remise en cause parce qu'on
l'a on l'a
allez allez violente elle elle frappe
elle tue parfois c'est une
c'est un racisme systémique qui se
retrouvent dans la police parce
qu'évidemment on a décidé par exemple
que ces populations dans nos quartiers
populaires les noirs les arabes étaient
des personnes dangereuses donc on va les
chasser
alors que ce ne sont pas des personnes
hors jose les gens dans les quartiers
populaires sont français les petits
jeunes là sont français ce qu'ils se
font attaquer régulièrement et contrôler
juste parce que les jeunes couleur de
peau qui ne convient pas à longueur de
journée d'ailleurs le défenseur de
droits on a des droits on a parlé d'un
soulier
c'est jusqu'à 20 fois plus de contrôles
quand on est un jeune noir un jeune
arabe par la police donc le climat de
peur que ressens tu sais ces gens là il
est pas lié à autre chose que
l'immigration illégale autre chose que
des migrations
il est lié à un contexte de racisme
systémiques liés à l'état et liées à la
police donc moi c'est ce qu'il faut
changer est évidemment l'immigration n'a
rien à voir dans tout ça puisque il
suffirait d'accueillir bien les gens qui
arrivent en france pourrait faire on est
un pays riche on est capable
d'accueillir correctement les gens qui
viennent en france les mettre dans des
conditions correctes et évidemment la
guerre des gangs
si certainement autre chose mais je
crois pas que la police puisse se régler
la guerre des gangs
en arrivant elle même avec des armes est
encore plus armé que la fois d'avant
scène jusqu'à cette notion d'
immigration paravent journal un cap et
d'un ça fait écho du côté de la place
beauvau puisque ce soir le ministre de
l'intérieur annonce un examen
systématique de l'expulsion des
étrangers impliqués justement dans ces
événements à dijon c'est une réponse qui
vous semblent satisfaisantes du côté du
rassemblement national
oui vous savez moi je me méfie toujours
de céder le gouvernement émet le
maquereau nous habituer a exprimé
beaucoup de mots et des maux
contradictoire avec bien sûr ceux qui
l'appliquent et sera donc élue
le ministère est une bonne part d'exane
donc moi je crois que dans les faits il
faut être beaucoup plus serré dans ces
moments là il faut restaurer l'état de
droit
on a une situation aujourd'hui qui est
grave dans certains quartiers et il faut
bien avant que la loi soit respectée
donc il faut moi je prends renforcer
justement les moyens
la police il faut soutenir la police au
contraire de ce qu'a fait au castanet
requis a failli la semaine dernière qui
a cédé aux revendications de la rue
d'une poignée d'ailleurs de manifestants
soutenus ou manipulés soit par l'extrême
gauche soit par la famille traoré donc
dont on peut pas dire que l es l et kim
familles d'enfants de choeur tout de
même mais je crois que non il faut
redonner confiance à la police
aujourd'hui leur redonner des moyens ils
y vivent
ils exercent leurs missions dans des
conditions difficiles je n'apprends pas
du tout raciste si à l'acte raciste
il faut bien sûr le traité et le
condamner mais je la crois innocente que
dans sa grande majorité extrêmement
sincère loyal et aux valeurs de la
république
et puis il faut aussi que la justice
fasse son boulot c'est à dire que des
délinquants ou des gens qui ont pu
participer à ces à ces scènes comme
celle de dijon depuis le 15 jours il
faut les interpeller il faut les juger
il faut les condamner sévèrement de
manière à ce que ce soit dissuasif
vikash dhorasoo vous avez fait pas mal
de manif
vous même vous parliez tout à l'heure de
ces échauffourées qui se sont produits
cet après midi dans les manifestations
de soignants vous dites voilà la police
a réprimé ces soignants qui se sont fait
applaudir pendant la crise est-ce que
tout de même vous accordez une forme de
crédit à ce que dit jean lain la capen
sur la manipulation est ce que ces
personnes qui viennent parfois cagoulés
vêtus de noirs dans les manifestations
et qui brouillent parce que ça ce sont
les soignants qu'ils disent c'est pas
moi qui le dit qui brouillent leurs
messages et leurs revendications est ce
que voilà vous pensé justement qui a
parfois aussi une forme de manipulation
alors juste pour répondre à monsieur
n'étions pas quelques personnes à la
place de république
la cause la république était bien plus
rempli le stade de france le soir d'un
match de finale de coupe du monde le
stade de france accueille 80 mille
personnes suis pas si vous vous rendez
compte le nombre de personnes qu'il y
avait là des jeunes noirs blancs arabes
asiatiques moi je suis d'origine
indienne réunis pour la même chose en
dénonçant les mêmes choses la violence
de la police des violences policières et
le racisme systémique qui vise une
certaine catégorie de la population donc
évidemment c'est pas quelque chose
dan oda autant de monde qui se
réunissent c'est pas anodin aussi que
nous tous étions d'accord à scander les
mêmes choses et ce jour là
évidemment il se passe rien la
manifestation est super le préfet
l'allemand l'autorisent peu après
l'interdît et puis en plus on est menacé
on est empêché de circuler par cette
police qui en même temps le jour-même
autorise une banderole néo nazis sur pas
par un groupe néonazi sur les murs et
qui après l'essai personnes parties
alors que nous on a été gazés alors
qu'on était complètement pacifique à
notre exemple pour contrôler ya
évidemment ce que ce que vous dites
c'est que aux états unis il ya pas si
longtemps les policiers ont dit ah si
c'est ça nous on bosse plus une partie
de la des policiers ont décidé de poser
les menottes comme vous l'a les
policiers récents l'ont fait et bien
bizarrement n'y a pas eu plus de
violence plus de crimes plus haut et a
même baissé
et puis je pense souvent à laurie
lightfoot qui étaient là
la maire de chicago une des villes les
plus violentes des états unis qui est
une femme noire et lesbiennes qui a
décidé de régler tous les problèmes
sociaux par des mesures sociales sans
jamais faire appel à la police
elle a baissé les violences dans la
ville à baisser l'insécurité le
sentiment d'insécurité parce
qu'évidemment ça n'existe pas parce que
juste moi je ne me sens pas en
insécurité dans ma ville par contre je
me sens pas en confiance quand je croise
un policier et sa syriennes à mon
histoire d'un enfant ici l'immigration
qui vient d'un quartier populaire
j'en ai la capelle sur justement le
désarmement de cette police est
effectivement à minneapolis on a démonté
la police cette idée pourrait faire son
chemin ce que ça vous inspire quoi
donc je prends ce n'est pas le problème
mais je voudrais quand même revenir sur
l'a8 française qui est une et
indivisible et l'invisible ça veut dire
zéro que bédarrides comme ceux dhorasoo
dit qu'il y avait à cette manifestation
des blancs des noirs
les gens de toutes les couleurs moi cela
m'est totalement égal pour moi il ya des
français qui ne sont pas français mais
quelle que soit la couleur de peau
l'origine la religion des gens quelles
que soient leurs racines
ça m'est totalement égal j'estime que on
est français par d'autres choses mais
n'a mans et notamment par le respect des
valeurs à notre république française
vous faites allusion de ce dhorasoo la
manifestation il ya quelques jours elle
m'a mise en fait votre réflexion parce
que ces manifestations illégales
donc en termes de respect de lois et de
modèles et d'exemple je souris un petit
peu d'autre part vous parlez d'une
manifestation qui déclare n qui exprime
un message quand ils racines très bien
moi j'ai entendu du sale juif et du sale
blanc pendant cette manifestation et
enfin ça c'est quand même terminé par
des dégradations matérielles dont on
sait que ce sont les français avec un
beau qui régleront cela donc qu'ils
apprécieront donc vous pouvez pas d'un
côté demander plus de justice et de
l'autre côté ne pas la respecter
je crois qu'il ya une contradiction dans
ce que vous dites mais ceci ne me
surprend pas de la france soumise dans
laquelle vous de vous pour taken to
maison votre réponse des cages dhorasoo
et puis le mot de la france c'est que le
la journée contre ibères comme vous
dites
elle sert aussi à payer la police alors
donc on a le droit d'avoir un mot sur
cette police qui nous pour pour nous
frapper et bornes où tu me lis donc
c'est aussi nous qui la payons juste
lorsqu'il ya eu les moments un peu
qu'ils ont cafouillé
c'est des gens du comité à damas qui ont
protégé qui ont empêchés et qui ensuite
se sont fait taper par la police ait eu
qui empêchait les casseurs ils se sont
mis devant ils ont pêché à ça traoré a
condamné les propos
antisémite d'une seule personne après je
voudrais juste vous parliez de mâcon
tout à l'heure macron n'a pas soutenu la
manifestation il a soutenu la police
dans son intervention il a soutenu la
police qui est violente et n'a pas parlé
des violences policières
donc il a soutenu donc il a évidemment
je me pense je pense un peu parlé aussi
à l'extrême droite qui est inquiet de ne
pas nous moi les gens qui étions à la
manifestation nous sommes français
nous ne voulons pas de séparatisme vaut
pas faire bande à part nous voulons
juste l'égalité
nous voulons être traités comme les
autres quand les pales du privé s blanc
on pense que être blanc dans la sphère
publique
c'est un avantage de ne pas par exemple
ne pas se faire contrôler trouver un
appartement est bas nous voulons la même
chose ne pas être contrôlé quand on est
un homme de couleur
et puis là la démocratie le libres et
égaux en droits ben faut que ce soit
vrai aussi c'est pas vrai vous voulez
prendre la place d'un homme noir kabyle
dans un quartier populaire monsieur vous
allez voir si on est libres et égaux en
droit en france à lévis fait le prenez
la place faite le et pourquoi
aujourd'hui sinon très mal en pis quand
vous interpeller mais rapidement parce
qu'on arrive à la fin donc on vient de
voir l'illustration ses longues qui
d'ailleurs dû descendre racialiste le ce
dhorasoo qui parle depuis les blancs
mais monsieur le rat cela dit même
twitter qu'il était d'origine indienne
je crois que son papa était mauricien il
est arrivé en france il ya quelques
années à pau a été accueillie
parfaitement par la police française il
a pu travailler dans les chantiers
navals du havre monsieur dhorasoo vous
vous même dû profiter des institutions
ont profité des centres d'entraînement
profiter des services publics et vous
êtes devenu un grand footballeur
international
tout ceci vous lever la rue française
dont la plus française n'est pas raciste
elle est une indivisible encore faut-il
les mais encore faut-il l'épousé encore
utile la respecter ne pas cracher dans
la soupe et respecter ses lois
voilà mon mot de la fin merci à tous les
deux genres avec apple vikash dhorasoo
d'avoir accepté ce débat en direct sur
rt france